let's set it over to Nancy who's got a
very special guest with us today Melissa
rivers is here I do but we should call
her actress Melissa rivers nice is that
weird it's very well it's rare to have
you here congratulations you have a role
in the new movie enjoy which stars
Jennifer Lawrence but the most special
part about this role is that you're
playing your mother Joan on her QVC show
yes I am we have the first clip so let's
take a look
Joan Cindy say good luck to Joy wow you
look great good luck today ok black
that's her that session is blossom but
she should be in a skirt she's got nice
long legs show her legs good luck don't
even know her I worked hard on her
speech pattern but not so much the
accidents I didn't want it to be an
imitation yeah or a caricature am i
wrong but are your eyes here enough I
can't watch myself and especially like
that I think I was so focused on the
details and trying to do a good job that
it never hit me that I took this crazy
emotional risk until I got home and went
what did I just do how did it come about
exactly uh my agent receiving a phone
call saying David O'Russell wants to
meet Melissa and it was all very
hush-hush and top-secret note ok you
know it you know in our family o8 when
they offer a job I always joke is yes
and then how much so it was a little bit
of yes and oh my god
what would you like working with
Jennifer Lawrence